on this saturday night
the unprecedented election in
newfoundland and labrador
hours before the vote in-person ballots
are cancelled
going to level five is a pretty big
shock how the variant moved quickly in a
province on the brink of a change in
government
the end of the impeachment of donald
trump but will the former president go
gently into the night
plus oxford is testing the vaccine on
children in case the vaccination program
needs to be expanded and the black
academy
think about the people with the talent
that we haven't seen
the two brothers creating a new
generation of artists
global national with robin gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us election day in newfoundland and
labrador has been derailed by covet 19.
the province is now at its highest alert
level health officials have confirmed a
surge in new cases is linked to the new
variant that first emerged in the united
kingdom
less than 12 hours before polls were due
to open the province's chief electoral
officer
called off in-person voting switching
gears to allow voting by mail only
as ross lord reports that's a first in
canadian
election history in newfoundland and
labrador
people who thought they'd be going out
to vote are staying in
following a lockdown order by health
authorities an order reinforced by
emergency alerts on phones
and on tvs we are at alert level 5
follow public health measures stay at
home
avoid non-essential travel authorities
are imposing restrictions
first seen when the pandemic started
only essential businesses remain
open hospitals and long-term care homes
are off limits to visitors
with limited exceptions everybody is in
somewhat of a panic like you know
they're getting tested for covet that
like they never have before i guess
escape especially since the covet 19
outbreak was traced
to the variant first identified in the
uk which is considered highly contagious
at least the daily count of new cases
which reached 100 two days ago
is now declining we have 26 new
confirmed cases of covid19 in our
province
authorities say there's not enough
evidence to prove the worst is over
there's a lot of things we have to work
out this weekend
you know going to level five is a pretty
big shock for we're just
having just been announced last night at
8 30 so we're
absorbing a lot of things things like
how to choose their next government
i am suspending in-person voting for all
40 provincial electoral districts
in-person voting will not be rescheduled
the entire election was shifted to
mail-in ballots
requiring voters to register online but
obstacles are already appearing
the chief electoral officer says he's
hearing the concerns of people about
accessibility to computers and internet
and the inability to provide
identification digitally
planners are now offering to approve
mail and kits to voters over the phone
if they can prove they're on the voters
list there are complaints
some people could be left behind like in
labrador where communities are hampered
by language barriers
spotty phone and internet service and
slow mail service
it often takes three to four weeks for
mail from st john's to arrive
to the region so even if everyone
applies for their special ballot today
i don't know if the ballots are gonna
show up before the date that they're due
back
in st john's election officials hope
using express
post will speed up the process enabling
all voters to return their ballots by
march 1st
but there's no guarantee the province
will pull off this makeshift election
successfully ross lord global news
breaking news tonight out of washington
d.c the senate voted and acquitted
donald trump
the former president was accused of
inciting the riots in the american
capital
a conviction was unlikely but the
democrats were determined and at the
last minute
even tried to call in witnesses let's
bring in reggie chichini who's been
watching the impeachment trial from the
beginning reggie this obviously is not a
surprise but you can't say dc
is lacking political drama yeah robin
that's for sure and even as donald trump
sits at his florida resort he remains an
ever steady presence in washington
house managers for the last week tried
to remind jurors that they themselves
were victims of the attack at the u.s
capitol but republicans for the last
four years
have learned the lesson of crossing
trump which is why so few of them opted
to go that route
closing on the arguments built during
the week senators
this cannot be the beginning
it can't be the new normal it has to be
the end
house impeachment managers work to
convince republicans that trump's
rhetoric linked to an election lie
resulted in the attack on the capitol
donald trump
knew the people he was inciting leading
up to january the sixth
he saw the violence they were capable of
trump's defense meanwhile stuck with
arguments about process
and that their client was the victim of
a never-ending hunt
the house manager's false narrative is a
brazenly dishonest attempt
to smear to cancel constitutional
canceled culture their number one
political opponent
but as republicans geared up to hand
trump his second impeachment acquittal
a nearly three-hour delay almost
derailed the proceedings
we would like the opportunity to
subpoena congresswoman
herrera house impeachment managers
called the last minute vote for
witnesses
there's a little confusion here
democrats wanted to speak with a
republican lawmaker who had
details of a phone call between donald
trump and the top-ranking republican in
the house kevin mccarthy
while the riot was underway this is an
additional
critical piece of corroborating evidence
after a lengthy delay
democrats simply read the account into
the record which trump's lawyers
agreed was accurate but still the idea
of calling any witnesses
riled up republicans but also revealed
the strength of party loyalty
the reason you're seeing this this hail
mary
is everybody knows the outcome of this
proceeding
it's a jarring comment since senators
swear an oath to be impartial jurors
and while the house attempted to sway
undecided senators
the defense offered an avenue to trump
loyalists
to vote without fear of political
fallout
reggie so after all is said and done was
this an exercise in futility
well robin it isn't insignificant that
seven republicans broke rank it's the
most bipartisan impeachment in u.s
history
and despite voting not guilty mitch
mcconnell afterwards laid blame on
donald trump for the riots saying that
he's liable for everything he did well
in office adding
that he didn't get away with anything
yet a hint that even though the
political court may have worked in
trump's favor ongoing criminal
investigations
could still pose problems for the former
president robin
reggie jacini in washington thanks
reggie
chinese telecom giant huawei is suing
the british bank hsbc
in a bid to stop the extradition of cfo
mong wang zhou to the u.s
hmong was arrested in vancouver at the
request of the american government
she's accused of misleading the bank
about the relationship between huawei
and its subsidiary skycom which was
allegedly doing business with iran
in retaliation china arrested two
canadian men
our mercedes stevenson has spoken with
huawei canada's vp of government affairs
about the company's response to those
arrests mercedes
robin it's been over two years since
michael spavor and michael kovrig
were arbitrarily detained in china
following the arrest of huawei cfo
mung wong zhou they sit in a chinese
prison
as mung wang zhou is under house arrest
in vancouver
awaiting an extradition ruling
immigration officials gave permission
for mong wang jo's family to travel to
canada
meanwhile the michaels only have very
limited consular access
on wednesday the biden administration
called on china to release the two
michaels
calling their detention unacceptable
this comes in a week where china cracked
down on media freedom
expelling bbc world news from the
country
there are concerns about huawei's
connection to the chinese government
and potential complicity in alleged
human rights abuses
but despite all that huawei canada wants
the canadian government to let
them build a 5g network here this week
on the west block i talked to the vice
president of government affairs for
huawei canada
morgan elliott i repeatedly pressed him
on whether his company
would condemn the detention of the two
michaels here's that exchange
well as as a company we want everyone
home we want to send in one showbox
as well you you see that as equal you
see those as as
as morally equal the detention of mong
wong joe under a legitimate arrest
warrant out of the united states
that had an extradition on it and
picking up random canadian citizens and
throwing them in jail for two years at a
time
again this was actions that were outside
of the company
uh we're not a political entity we're
not a political government we're a tech
company that wants to do business right
but if you want to do business we want
all the families
then canadians would like to know if you
see these two situations as equal why
would canadians want
your company to be doing business here
elliott also excused the company's
application for a patent that would have
involved development of technology to
recognize and monitor the persecuted
minority uyghur population in china
as a mistake and insisted that canada's
electronic spy agency has publicly said
that huawei is safe
but when global news reached out to the
communication security establishment
canada
we found out that's not true cse has
never commented publicly on huawei the
agency
told us robin mercedes stevenson in
ottawa thanks mercedes and you can see
the full interview tomorrow on the west
block
right here on global the federal
government is preparing to table its
first budget
since the pandemic began finance
minister christia freeland has spent the
past several weeks talking to economists
mayors and canadians from all walks of
life
to find out what they want to see in the
next fiscal update
our chief political correspondent david
aiken joins us and david there's talk of
an agenda item
that may help parents well robin it's no
surprise that the trudeau government a
self-described
feminist government has made improving
child care a
top policy goal finance minister
christopher freeland said so herself in
last fall's economic statement
we are laying the foundation for a
canada-wide
early learning and child care system
one of the next bricks in that
foundation could well be a tax credit
an internal government poll obtained by
global news shows that the privy council
office
was asking canadians late last year
about a tax credit
worth five thousand dollars for each
child in child care
turns out though only about 52 percent
of parents
thought a tax credit should be ottawa's
top child care priority and
experts say tax credits are unlikely to
help i think it is
the path of least resistance because it
means they don't have to get involved in
actually the quality
or the standards of care but it does not
create one
more new space that is high quality
another idea floated in the pco poll
providing a cash
subsidy of twenty dollars a day per
child
the pco poll found that idea very
popular with women
62 percent of female respondents said
that should be the top priority
versus 47 of men but perhaps most
alarming is that the pco poll found that
one in three parents that had children
enrolled in child care pre-pandemic
had not been able to get their kids back
into a program
by december and that's one of the
primary causes of the economic
phenomenon
elnisian has called the she session no
recovery without a she covered
and no she covered without child care is
mathematically
impossible to get to recovery without
making sure
women have a safe place to leave their
kids
now freelance office would not confirm
if child care tax credits or
cash subsidies will actually be in the
budget but her office did say that
freeland remains
as committed now ahead of her first
budget as she did last fall in the
fiscal update
to improving child care robin david
aiken in ottawa thanks david
there are concerns about the spread of
coven 19 in toronto's homeless shelters
especially one
involving a new variant public health
officials are conducting tests to
determine which variant was identified
at a shelter run by the salvation army
there are a total of eight known
covin-19 infections confirmed at the
facility so far
all the infected residents and their
close contacts have been relocated
to a designated isolation and recovery
site
at the city's largest men's shelter
seton house the number of active cases
has doubled over the past 10
days there were at least 43 known
infections as of friday
none of the cases at this shelter has
been linked to the new variants
in the uk the oxford astrazeneca
covenanting vaccine will soon be tested
on
children the study will assess the
immune responses in roughly 300 kids
between the ages of 6 and 17. they're
expected to get their first shot
this month pfizer and moderna began
similar trials last year
the university of oxford's chief
researcher says the testing is needed in
case
mass vaccination programs are extended
to children
it is certainly possible that wider use
to try and curb the
progress of the pandemic might be
considered in the future
and so here really we're just trying to
establish the data
that will support that if if indeed
policymakers wanted to go in that
direction
the united kingdom is on track to meet
its first mass vaccination target
so far more than 14.5 million people
have received at least
one shot the british government had
promised to give 15 million people the
vaccine by monday
prime minister boris johnson says he's
optimistic kova 19 lockdown measures
could be eased soon
coming up the deadly consequences of
fossil fuels and what the world
needs to do about it
it's long been known that pollution from
burning fossil fuels is extremely
harmful to our health
a new report paints a much darker
picture it
estimates more than 8 million people die
every year
after breathing the emissions that are
left in the air as redmond shannon
reports
experts believe making the move to
renewable energy is more critical
than ever before
air pollution is a huge health issue
particularly in rapidly developing
nations
the most recent estimates had said 4
million people die
every year due to the microscopic pm
2.5 particles released when burning
fossil fuels and
biomass but now researchers led by
harvard university say it could be more
than
double that number even when the effects
of forest fires wood burning and dust
are excluded we estimate just from
fossil fuel combustion
that there are 8.7 million premature
deaths
each year that means almost one in five
adult premature deaths worldwide could
be down to pollution coming from burning
coal oil and gas scientists used
existing data that links emissions and
disease
and then added a mathematical model that
divided the world into smaller segments
it helped identify how dense pockets of
pollution
can affect deaths and so what we could
do with the simulation is tease out the
contribution from fossil fuel combustion
and so when we combined those two tools
we estimated premature mortality that's
much greater than
previously reported more than half the
deaths are in china and
india though both countries are taking
measures to reduce
pollution the report estimates that more
than 13 percent of premature adult
deaths in canada were caused by fossil
fuel pollution in 2018.
broken down by province ontario was the
highest at more than
17 newfoundland and labrador was less
than two percent
however the data they used for canada is
already somewhat outdated
and there is a wide margin of error but
the results are still
broadly in line with what canadian
experts have seen
what some of these newer studies are
finding is that even at relatively
low concentrations relatively good air
we still
see a significant impact in terms of
increased risk to our health that risk
caused by pollutants is on top of the
impacts of climate change
the drive to net zero must become the
new normal for everyone everywhere
for every country every company city
financial institution
the un's crucial cop 26 climate change
summit is scheduled for november in
glasgow
when each nation is expected to present
more ambitious targets
for reducing emissions redmond shannon
global news
london still ahead myanmar's
pro-democracy protests enter a second
week but will the military
relent
building shook in japan when a 7.1
magnitude earthquake struck off the
country's northeastern coastline
the quake hit just after 11 pm local
time near the site of the fukushima
nuclear disaster
there were widespread power outages and
dozens of people were injured
the tremors were felt hundreds of
kilometers away in the capital tokyo
defiant protests against the military
coup in myanmar have entered a second
week
hundreds of demonstrators gathered
outside the u.s and chinese embassies in
yangon
the country's largest city demanding the
release of aung san tsuchi
thousands more took to the streets in
the capital earlier this month the
military seized power ending half a
decade of democracy
under sushi
protests initially planned to show
support for myanmar's pro-democracy
movement
in thailand quickly morphed into wild
demonstrations against laws
that punish people for mocking the king
scuffles broke out as protesters pushed
for the release of four activists
arrested for insulting thailand's king
a crime that amounts to 15 years in
prison
up next the academy supporting black
talent in canada
often canadians have to make it in the
u.s before their talent is recognized
and celebrated here at home
that problem is significantly worse for
black creatives in this country
a lack of support and opportunities in
canada has led to a gap in black
representation in the arts
as kayla mclean explains it's why two
canadian brothers are stepping up to
help
the next generation gentlemen right here
together
they starred in big box office dramas
and garnered award show recognition
please join me in honoring my little
brother
but for toronto raised actors and
brothers to fond james and shanir
anderson
their hollywood success is tempered by a
deep sense of responsibility to change
the industry
at home four or five years ago you know
shamir and i were seeing much of the
same problems that we see today
um you know in terms of just there being
a lack of support
and celebration and recognition of you
know black artists doing incredible
things
the lack of opportunity support and
visibility for black creatives in this
country sparked the brothers next act
the black academy a first of its kind in
canada
and a way to foster and showcase black
talent there's not enough
governing bodies infrastructures places
to celebrate black excellence
i mean when black people slip and fall
we see that all over the news
it's very rare we get to hear the
pinball clemens of the world we're doing
incredible stuff
very little data exists on black
creators both behind
and on the screen in canada but the
stats that do exist paint a troubling
picture
racialized and black communities make up
about 22 percent of the population in
this country
but according to the black screen office
in the history of television
broadcasting
only five shows led by black creatives
have made it onto canadian television
for longtime canadian writer and
producer jennifer holness the stark
disparity means a huge cultural loss and
perpetuation of systemic racism in the
canadian industry
think about all we have lost
think about the stories that haven't
been told
think about the people with the talent
that we haven't seen shamir and stefan
hope to combat those inequities by
bringing black talent to the fore in
canada
but much needed financial backing for
the black academy is proving to be
elusive
outside of the canada media fund no
other organization has stepped up to
pledge their financial support
something shamir is calling on the
government and corporate canada
to change fostering talent but not just
you know a one-time check that's cut
from the government because someone
feels bad today
you know it's not that it's
sustainability it's permanent
kayla mclean global news to learn more
about how the brothers hope to make real
and lasting change
watch the new reality with donna friesen
tonight right here on global and that is
global national for this saturday night
i'm robin gill we leave you with a rare
sight in vancouver bc
it's snowing the city woke up to a
winter wonderland
thank you for watching we'll see you
back here tomorrow have a great night
[Music]